la bentley aller là bas avec al qods à
loches l'état rival à cette partie on
arrête les gens dans la rue et dès
qu'ils nous répondent dans se déguise
deux fois plus dur des deux déguisement
a trouvé voilà c'est pixar qu'est ce que
vous pensez des transports en commun
paris le métro héros pratique et vous
êtes de paris pas du tout et votre frère
il en pense quoi
mon frère aucune idée grosso modo la
même chose
il a failli à deux et votre frère yvon
lambert quoi la chance d'être des
triplés en fait nous donc ça s'entend
super bien
la baisse j'ai pris le métro les bus
jacou raté mais j'ai 30 ans quoi bayard
haineux et votre frère il en pense quoi
j'ai pas très bien comment vas tu dois
acheter
sortez prison là alors on société vous
n'allez pas tarder à y retourner
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
personnellement je trouve que les
transports parisiens sont deux de très
bon niveau est le frère de l'autre elle
en pense quoi
et le frère de mon fin et l'enfance à
peu près la même chose
ça va très bien enchantée voilà sa
voiture ce soir oui mais ressort comme
d'habitude pour buffalo
forcément c'est passé vite aya que des
francs maçons et koné à téloche cj
manatee sa pyramide qu'est ce que vous
pensez des transports en commun
parisiens
j'habite au canada et j'éprouve que les
trois parisiennes est fantastique c'est
vite et intéressante et j'adore et la
soeur de votre sort qu'est ce que l'on
pense t elle en pense quoi
pour eux pas nous les adaptons famille
négligent tout cas tu quoque fili fla
flu ok y'a 06 ou idiote
bonjour p 4
ap ap les talibans